so the fighting dies down and that sets
up for now the next phase right right
and you can tell us a little bit so
hooker is going to call for some
reinforcements and he has general Edwin
Sumner who's in charge of the second
Corps he's McClellan is going to send
two of his divisions to assist hooker
they've been east of the creek that
morning so they haven't been in that
initial fighting that you just described
and so Sumner is going to send two of
his own divisions to attack what he
thinks is a very vulnerable Confederate
Left Flank he thinks he can hit Lee on
the left and simply roll him up through
the Westwoods so moving north to south
rolling up that that Left Flank and so
his plan is to send a division under
John Sedgwick Sedgwick has about 5 000
men
they are going to to start their attack
but it immediately is a problem because
they are in a tight formation and we've
talked a bit about linear lines in in
our opening lecture but here this is a
really tight formation 5 000 men they're
spread out in Brigade length battle
lines that are about 500 yards long and
if we can imagine a football field think
about 500 500 yards five football fields
long they're only about 50 feet excuse
me 50 yards separating each of the
brigades so this is a really tight
formation and what this means is they
can't maneuver they they cannot turn to
adjust so they have filed into the
Westwoods again assuming that there are
no Confederates right in front of them
and just at the moment that they enter
the Westwoods they are immediately hit
with all of these Confederate
reinforcements this is another place in
which going to the battlefield is
imperative you can see the limestone
rocks that the outcroppings the places
the swales and the land that allowed the
Confederates to to hide and so Sedgwick
has completely caught off guard moreover
his men can't maneuver they they can't
turn to their left they can't turn to to
respond to the Confederates and they
quickly find themselves surrounded from
behind they are almost enveloped they
are surrounded on the left and the right
and and eventually from behind and this
just leads to a Breaking Point there's a
lot of Friendly Fire as well try to turn
and they shoot into their own men right
absolutely and so Sumner will order them
to retreat he's yelling at them to to
evacuate the Westwoods and they're going
to start falling back and he's yelling
back back you're you're in a bad fix but
this just like the cornfield this is
another incredible horrific killing
ground I threw about 50 casualties here
in the Westwoods it's the greatest
disaster on the union side that day
absolutely they're on the cusp they
believe on a significant Victory right I
mean Sumner thinks that West Woods is
cleared of any Confederates and he
wouldn't listen to anybody else
McClellan had little faith in Sumner I
don't know it's because there was a
rumor that Sumner's skull was so thick
that musket Falls would bounce off and
that's a great rumor I suspect it's
probably not true probably not but I
think you would test that it would be
difficult one to test but McClellan
certainly did not trust Sumner at all
and of course what happened in the West
Woods I think validated that I said note
that Sumner was so rattled by what
happened in the West Woods that he
reported to McCall and basically that
nothing more could be done on that flank
that flank's paper thin still right and
here's again another example of the back
and forth Savage Fierce fighting it
almost always ends in a draw and that's
what happens and so this morning fight
comes to an end the as the fighting is
ending in the Westwoods the union attack
shifts toward the Confederate Center
somewhere around 10 o'clock that morning
so what happens does McClellan order
this attack
so here's a classic example of where
McClellan did not leave his imprint on
the battlefield now it is true that Army
commanders should not have any control
over tactics but but
the center of the Confederate line was
one of the few places on the battlefield
that McClellan could see and rather than
directing and reinforcing and supporting
the union attacks that happened there he
basically held back much needed reserves
much needed reserves to support what
amounted to four major Union assaults
against you described earlier the sunken
Lane you go there today you can see that
Old Farmer's Lane it's a perfect
defensive position however if you look
to the front of that Confederate
position you'll note that that open
ground that the Union Soldiers had to
charge across that open ground often put
them on a higher Plateau right right a
higher Ridge line looking down into the
Confederates so these classic frontal
attacks back and forth and the
Confederates
they embarked upon what would be called
like a fluid defense there's at least
two Confederate counter attacks that
occurred there so it again typical the
fighting that occurred on the
Confederate left leg happened at the
Confederate Center as well ultimately
the Confederates were overwhelmed really
by numbers there's also some
miscommunication of orders in the sunken
Lane some Confederates pull out which
triggered a massive withdrawal but the
Confederate Center dissolved McClellan
saw it all desperate for reinforcements
desperate for artillery there's the
moment he could have divided these Army
into two
but he did not do it but he didn't and
one of the really important things about
visiting this ground is I've often had
students that are are making that Union
attack and if you put people down in the
sunken Lane you can see where
Confederates held the advantage for for
such a long period of time but as soon
as those Union troops come up over the
hill then they are standing it's kind of
like shooting fish in a barrel it
absolutely is and one of those Union
Soldiers is an Indiana Soldier David
beam 14th Indiana who occupied that High
Ground looking down into the sun can lay
his regiments suffered terribly as did
the Confederacy was firing into and
after the battle he wrote this uh this
letter to his wife
when I reflect what a terrible ordeal we
have passed through and how many have
fallen around me I feel very thankful
that I have been so remarkably preserved
I presume that at least a half a dozen
men were killed within six yards of me
and some of them fell at my feet
what's interesting here we're going to
talk a quote from one of his comrades in
the 14th Indiana
William Houghton I think it's always
fascinating how these soldiers make
decisions as writers as to what the
people back home what they're going to
take from this experience at the second
race
to William Houghton again of the 14th
Indiana wrote on September 20th
I saw many Brave boys fall like sheep
led to the slaughter
Bryant was shot through the brain
cord was shot near the heart
and while the lifeblood was gushing from
the Moon
he sat up and with an almost Heavenly
smile playing upon his features
he told us he was dying but to not mind
him farewell Captain he exclaimed he
reached toward him and he fell forward
to the Earth
now the men they were fighting were from
Alabama I have a quote from a survivor
of the sunken Lane and what's striking
about this quote is that we can sense
the Deep sense of loss of mourning that
these men felt for comrades that had
been killed they felt so strongly about
these men the men that they fought with
and the sense of loss it truly
overwhelmed them as we will get a sense
of from this Alabama Soldier
he wrote on October the 14th
I often think of our trip to Maryland
how many of the Brave comrades went into
Maryland
with Bright Hopes of the future that are
now in the cold grave
I frequently think of Bob who did not
see him when he was shot
perhaps he was left when he fell and his
bones May whiten on the top of the
ground
tell your father and mother that he died
like a patriot and a true Soldier and
not as a coward
I wish I could write something that
would be encouraging them
but I know nothing and my heart is too
heavy to think of anything
so this great opportunity that was
presented to McClellan at the
Confederate Center did I capitalize upon
it the fighting then shifted toward the
Confederate right flank should tell us a
little bit about McClellan and his key
subordinate down there Ambrose e
Burnside it was ordered or instructed to
strike the Confederate right flank right
so Burnside who's in charge of the ninth
Corps
has the one of the the greatest
possibilities on the field in terms of
getting around the Confederate right
flank they can get around the
Confederate right flank they can cut off
access to the Ford Butler's Ford which
is the only Avenue of Escape that Lee
has to get back across the Potomac River
but the problem is the Confederates have
probably the most defensible position on
the field overlooking What's called the
lower bridge but will soon bear
burnside's name will come to be known as
burnside's bridge and I think it's worth
talking for a bit about what this place
looks like what it looked like then and
what it looks like now
you can go and stand on the Confederate
position there are about 500
Confederates they're technically under
the command of General Robert Toombs but
Colonel Henry binning is overseeing the
Tactical Arrangements there and these
are steep Bluffs that they're
overlooking the the slow-moving Creek
the creek is only about 20 feet wide but
it's four to four and a half feet deep
means that you can't Wade across it
there's no way and if if you do if
you're a soldier you're going to have to
put your your rifle above your head to
keep it from getting wet yeah I don't
think there's a timeout in battle right
no no there's no time to Wade the creek
and allow that to happen Confederate uh
also has artillery they have about 12
guns that are placed on this High ground
and the Georgians are are occupying
there this was an Old Quarry there's
pits there they're also in the trees
again incredibly uh strong defensive
position you don't you don't need a lot
of them in there to hold it don't need
many men there and again Burnside has
the entire ninth core at his disposal
the problem on the other side of the
creek is that it's a small open area
it's but it's almost a Ravine and the
the bridge itself is quite narrow and so
you can't send men rushing across at
least in any Force so this is an
incredibly strong position that Burnside
is is going to have to take on yeah I
think it's you know worth repeating you
know how strong this Confederate
position was and particularly the bridge
it's a funnel right it brings these
attackers into a column position they're
utterly defenseless there's at least
what three attempts to try to cross the
bridge and they are absolutely gunned
down so you know people go to burnside's
bridge today and they like to say well
look at Burnside he's obsessed with the
bridge why didn't he just go Downstream
and cross
well he was trying to he's trying to he
was trying to so there's a Ford that
they've heard about it's called
snavely's Ford he's been trying to send
men out throughout the day to find this
Fords where they can cross cross the
creek again it's a creek but it's not
one that you can easily cross and he's
been sending men out there are bad Maps
bad intelligence so it takes late in the
day before they find this place in which
the ninth Corps can can cross so he has
you're absolutely right he sent several
attempts across the bridge but it's not
until late in the afternoon when finally
this Ford is located and the bulk the
the the ninth Corps is able to cross the
creek and come up swing up behind the
Confederate for the final assault for
the final assault right right and the
assault that for the federals still has
a distinct possibility of crushing these
Army by
cutting thee off from the forge you
mentioned before right Butler's Ford
right but you can go to today and you
can see it and uh that's it and you know
this again is audacity Persona 5 but in
such a way that man this borderline's on
being Reckless we all know maximum of
War you should not have your army up
against the river and when you've got
one route against to get across to the
other side that is incredibly risky
right but there is still that chance
late in the afternoon after Burnside is
crossed Antietam Creek right it's about
one o'clock yeah Burnside manages to to
to cross the creek the the bridges in
Union High Union hands it's it's this is
what they've been trying to do but it's
come at a significant cost absolutely
going after that bridge all afternoon
absolutely he still has it has he still
has Burnside has about 8 000 men right
so he has a massive front and I just
want to again keep sort of plugging our
Park Service friends I don't think
there's another Battlefield in the
Eastern theater that of the park any
park has done a better job than Antietam
and creating Trails so that you can walk
in the footsteps of these men you can
walk burnside's attack from the Steep
Bluffs above burnside's bridge over what
we call burnside's Bridge all the way to
the Confederate final lie which is on
the outskirts of the town of Sharpsburg
absolutely but you got to be in shape
because there is rugged ground it's the
most treacherous territory anywhere on
the battlefield it's up and down and up
and down and you can easily imagine that
late afternoon assault long lines of
federal troops as they go toward their
goal right and that is to cut Lee's army
off from the Potomac it was such a
desperate situation this I believe I
believe is the first time that Ariel
ever came under Fire he is on the edge
of town trying to Rally stragglers you
know creating again this just it's a
paper thin line and as the federals make
their advance and they're again this is
just what did happen throughout the day
they're on the cusp delivering that
knockout blow but who arrived at the
very last moment none other than go
ahead Carrie you did it it was AP Hill
AP Hills come in from Harpers Ferry so
tell us about that final assault yeah
what happens so what happens to that
final assault that the Federalists are
getting they're on the verge of breaking
the Confederate lawn and AP Hills men
who were at started the day at Harpers
Ferry how long is that March 12 to 15
miles somewhere in that range they're
going hard there's a fair amount of
straggling but when they reach the scene
it's right at the perfect time for the
Confederates and at the perfect place
because they struck burnside's line
right at the Left Flank the farthest
most regiment was a Connecticut regiment
they had just got into service hell many
of these men didn't even know how to
work their guns they're down in a low
ground and AP AP Hills men devour them
right devour them and that of course
destabilized the entire front for
Burnside so Brightman Sharpsburg and the
Confederate right flank were about ready
to uh to collapse Apo arrival sent
burnside's men reeling backwards and so
what do we have we have the armies
occupy the ground that they basically
held when the day started right this
slugfest has amounted almost right now
is there a clear Victor there's not a
clear Victor here uh both sides will
make their case the day where the
Victorious one for the federal side or
the northern side it was enough of a
victory because
retreated not on the 18th but on the
19th going across Butler's Ford and with
that Retreat that was enough for Abraham
Lincoln to make the claim right that
this was a union victory but today's
casualties of course they were
extraordinary there were over you know
23 000 men felt in a single day it's the
bloodiest day of the Civil War
and only if you go
to that Battlefield and walk that ground
can you fully appreciate why that
fighting was so intense why it was so
bloody great irony is it is a stalem
neither side gained a decisive advantage
in a military sense but politically
Lincoln now has that battle that victory
that he can declare the preliminary
emancipation and so in our next lecture
we'll talk about the Revolutionary
consequences of a battle that was
basically a draw
[Music]
thank you